how have you kept your relationships and
your minimalist life among people who
only care and talk about things and
money so Josh how do you uh well yeah
mostly everyone I hang out they just
talk about things and money well you
know you know it's funny reading this
question dude it makes me kind of
repository lationship s-- in your
minimalist of life among the shitty
relationships you had I mean so a long
time ago I I wrote an essay called
letting go of shitty relationships and
you can find on our website or put a
link to that in the show notes as well
man I'll tell you it's one of the most
difficult things I had to let go of so
you don't start with letting go of the
shitty relationships or the toxic people
but one thing you realize you have if
you have these victimizers in your life
they're going to continue to victimize
you now that's an extreme example and I
don't want you to be the victim of their
consumerism in a way right we all need
some stuff and I will talk about things
from time to time or things that I get
value where we'll talk about money from
time to time absolutely things and money
are two things that make the world go
round right right but I would much
rather talk about those things with
respect to our values and our desires
our needs our once as opposed to well
just a sort of vapid consumerism that is
propagated by advertisements and the
everyday media and so when I when I
think about Magdalena's question here
the the thing that I think about is man
you need some new friends and that's
okay yeah need some new friends and it
doesn't mean that your current friends
are evil no but they just don't align
with your values and beliefs and and
that's okay and you know what it may be
it may mean that you didn't know what
those values were for a really long time
and all of a sudden you're uncovering
those values and you're realizing that
many of the relationships that you have
right now are birthed out of proximity
and
convenience meaning you work in the
cubicle next to them there happened to
be they grew up in the same neighborhood
as you they attend the same networking
events or you you hang out at the same
bars or nightclubs go to the same school
yeah yeah and so you have these
relationships that are there because of
proximity but they're not birthed from
the same sets of values now I think
about my relationships and it's take a
long time you and I discovered
minimalism almost a decade ago now we
were just in Nashville and I have a
bunch of friends in Nashville so they're
certainly not relationships because of
proximity right we spent some time with
our friend Griffin house we went over to
hit the Griffin house house hold hey
don't worry don't worry Sean will clean
that up and really awesome yeah so so we
are Griffin houses house with him and he
has the two best kids I've ever met
the afterword I said hey I was talking
to Beck's on my hey BECs how can we get
our daughter to love me as much as
Griffins kids love me
and I had such a blast with his two kids
yeah and and just with the the
relationship that we've developed with
Griffin over the years he's he's one of
our favorite musicians ever and and not
only does he have great music so we
share similar values with respect to
creativity but we also we grew up in
similar situations we actually all grew
up in Ohio even though none of us live
there any male grew up in Dayton yeah
yeah and so he he has similar values to
us and so I don't see him all the time
we've maybe seen him twice in the last
year he was in LA doing a tour stop we
were in Nashville doing a tour stop and
when we do make time when we do we're in
the same city we make time for each
other yeah so in order for someone to be
my friend doesn't mean I need to see
them every single day the next day in
fact we went to go see Austin Hartley
Leonard here's another talented musician
he has a band called broken anchor you
can check out their music wherever you
get music love his music in fact his
song he has a song called Ohio even
though he's not from
hi oh so good one of my top five
favorite songs of all time and and I
love him and I love his wife Amy I
haven't seen them in four years they
used to live in Los Angeles before we
lived in Los Angeles and now that we
live in Los Angeles they live in
Nashville and it's been 40 I have talked
to him on the phone a couple times we
tax occasionally but we're able to pick
up when we're in the same city we have
the most meaningful times together and I
do this over and over and over
our good friend Adam who we went to high
school with I worked with the same
restaurant in high school we get to see
him once a year for lucky mmm but I have
some of the most meaningful
conversations with him on the phone or
in person when we do have the chance and
it's because I'm not starved for
spending every moment with them it'd be
nice if they live in the same city as me
but what's more important is their their
value structure and who they are as a
person and having those meaningful
relationships the quality is so much
more important than the quantity
absolutely man you know here's my guess
my short answer to Magdalena's question
so she asks again how have you kept your
relationships in your minimalist life
among people who only care and talk
about things and money
we didn't yeah we didn't keep those
people around and it's not and again
this isn't a judgment against those
folks it is if anything it's a judgment
against myself right and in saying like
well this is you know what this is where
my values and beliefs lie and I'm not
willing to compromise those and I don't
want to hang out with anyone who isn't
supporting those values and beliefs do
you like birthday cake Ryan I think what
a dumb question of course you do do you
like tuna steak you could take a
birthday out of there just any cake in
general do you like tuna yeah it's
pretty good yeah but when you mix the
two together it tastes awful tuna cake
patent-pending yeah try it out you let
me know how it works and that's that's
really work Magdalena building
minimalist bakers listening to this
right now and she's like I'm gonna do
tuna cake
look on Josh's face here's the thing
that's where Magdalena is absolutely she
is mixing tuna with cake and you're not
saying that one is great and one is
awful you're saying these there are two
things that don't work together anymore
in my life my values no longer work with
the values of the current people I
surround myself with so what is the
answer you have to change the people
around you because you can't change the
people around juice
you